um chucu diz raimundo feito amanhã pelo
nível técnico
a minha paixão é a essência especial
mundo invisível dos atos no mar com 11
funcionários do universo quer conhecer
que ora química e física enquanto tipo -
vou explicar a minha paixão pela ciência
tem que começar a abordar a importância
da ciência no conhecimento do mundo e
dos animais nos campos a tudo que
conhecemos o fluxo se for necessário e
shishin é ser um método chamado max
indivíduo quando eu tinha que se
comprova hipótese e deixou problemas ou
quase tudo o que nos rodeia através da
imprensa se copia chegam sempre o mesmo
resultado do encerramento também dê
força à função e tetro assim sempre anos
hipótese inicial contava temos uma nova
teoria científica como a teoria da
evolução da wii mote oriental a
atividade está ainda a teoria da
gravidade já que neuton muitas
exigências que o homem tem de ouvir em
cada uma da tarde gosto de frente
fenômenos eleitorais
na realidade uma apaixonada ao saber que
com assim sempre se vamos jogar e e pior
conseguindo pretendido com josé não
pensar em alterações químicas na tabela
periódica ter ligações e tratam de
intenções de comprovar documentalmente a
minha teoria de rodri que pretende
provar que recebia da maternidade
einstein está errada
a teoria de rodrigo a teoria do
ricochete assim tem hipótese de
hidrogênio possa ter feito ricochete com
um com duas pedras de frente mas a
comida uma com a outra coisa hoje e
domingo na espanha um dia poder visitar
o cérebro onde possa testar a hipótese
de um dia poder contribuir na fundação
chaparro
atualmente a cientistas de todo mundo
ajuda a procurar a teoria sobre o ser
humano a ciência aos portais do
conhecimento eo coreto e querem te dá
que os jovens conheçam bem o mundo em
que vivemos por ainda poder chave a
humanidade nosso planeta que tem
potencial mas sim a humanidade
obrigatória a sua atenção